بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه
معاذ بن جبل
امام of
the propet
معاذ يوم القيامه بين يدي العلماء برتوه
برتوه يعني برميه حجر
يحشر العلماء
ويحشر معاذ رضي الله عنه بين يديهم برميه
حجر
ذا معاذ رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم بعد معاذ اعلم امه
بالحلال والحرام معاذ بن جبل
الله
حلال حرام معاذ بن جبل
صلى الله عليه
معاذ رضي الله عنه
اللهم
[Silence]
ان الله تعالى معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه
سال كنت رديف النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
على حمار
فقال لي يا معاذ اتدري ما حق الله على
العباد وما حق العباد على الله قلت الله
ورسوله اعلم
معاذ رضي الله عنه ساد
‏I was
on a donkey
and said
you what
overaves are andaves
upon are
said الله andess
حق الله على العباد ان يعبدوه ولا يشركوا
به شيئا
الله
any
وحق العباد على الله اي حق العباد الذي
افترضه الله تعالى تكرما منه ورحمه
لعباده على نفسه
الا يعذب من لا يشرك به شيئا
‏to over himself
is that will notish
those do not associate any partners him
when we see a wording this in the
narrations of the propetahi
was the right
of upon slaves this
‏inent
our ex
to
upon
and con the ofaves upon
this is notaves
الله سبحانه وتالى
upon himself
that all those
and me
not assoating any partners
معاذ رضي الله عنه
قلت يا رسول الله افلا ابشر الناس
قال لا تبشرهم فيتكلوا
‏said do not tell the masses of people
they regress in their action
their
actions suffer
as a result of this what does that mean
their actions would suff
they would on that
on
الله سبحانه وتالى
kind
of
one of theks
الله سبحانه وى
[Silence]
decreases
what does that mean it increases instead
of decreases
‏an angely
[Silence]
parad
hyally
‏would this
would this increase their prayer their f
their focus would this increase their
fasting would this increase theirity
or would this be a cause to decrease
person would say I'm already there
already
‏I don't have to you so anyore
up
this is a major differ
in understanding
we look at men this occurred to this
happen to people who did this happen to
for instance the 10 companions of the
propet
who were guaranteed parad during their
لايف تايم العشره المبشرون بالجنه
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ابو بكر في
الجنه وعمر في الجنه وعثمان في الجنه وعلي
في الجنه الى اخره
ابن عباس tell صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏are paraded
all of them and these are considered to
be the 10 tag for parad
in their lifetime
when we look at their life
leading up to that moment
and then we examine their life after
this good news came to them
did it decrease
ممد صلى الله عليه وسلمر
and different
great
esteem that will be and have
did this decrease his actions or did
increase his actions
[Silence]
الله
سبحانه وتالى
‏So
will that so be parad
this person bec
عائشه بخاري مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه حتى تتفطر قدماه
‏that would stand in prayer
until his feet would split. Thein on his
feet would split his feet would swell
and start to crack
because he is in place so long in prayer
at night.
انسوا عائشه رضي الله عنها
بلال ابن رباح
يا رسول الله
اتفعل هذا
وقد غفر الله لك ما تقدم من ذنبك وما تاخر
الله سبحانه
‏inite
for
صلى الله عليه وسلم افلا اكون عبدا شكورا
‏than
الله
and
position of parad so and so is in parad
this is not to happen
without the cause behind that without
the mean what are the means to parad the
means to parad
الله سبحانه وتعالى
من يرد الله به خيرا
يفقهه في الدين من يرد الله به خيرا
يصب منه من يرد الله به خيرا يستعمله قبل
قبل موته
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سنه صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
يصب
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران
فاما الانسان اذا ما ابتلاه ربه فاكرمه
ونعمه فيقول ربي اكرما
واما اذا مات تلاه فقدر عليه رزقه فيقول
ربي اهانه كلاund
‏signed
person and a person find himself in
difficulty in
illness in poverty
in tribulation that this is someh a sign
that Allah ishing
اللهران
[Silence]
الله
any الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم ساد مسند الامام احمد
ان الله يعطي المال من يحب ومن لا يحب
ولا يعطي الايمان
الا من يحب
هيد صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
[Silence]
ايان
سبحانه وتعالى ايمان ايمان
ايمان
الله
قران سنه صلاه ايمان زكاه
‏and
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم tells us الله
of this worldlyalth
those loves and those not
only
good
knowledge
only to those he loves
‏informed
knowledge ised through with
meaning a person who knows what has
commanded him but he does not do it
this is a lack of knowledge even if they
know all theidence
[Silence]
‏and
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم tells us
الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وىy
could
prop صلى الله عليه
اذا رايت الله
يعطي العبد من الدنيا
على معاصيه ما يحب فاعلم انما هو استدراج
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يعلمنا من كتابه ما جهلنا وان يذكرنا منه
ما نسينا وان يعلمنا الحكمه منه والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
اشهد لا
اله
الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
حي
على الصلاه
على
حي
على الفلاح
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
[Silence]
بسم الله
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح ي لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فان الله تعالى
يقول في كتابه الكريم
واعتصموا بحبل الله جميعا ولا تفرقوا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
احد
سوره ال عمران
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى
عليه وسلم
استووا
ولا تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
in
your divided.
‏So this minor infraction
of the row not being so straight. We got
some brothers a little bit ahead
behind
the row isn't as coherent and straight
as it should be. This will invariably
lead to a differing in the hearts.
And a differing in the hearts leads to a
differing in the religion itself.
‏most innovation
when you
look to the innovations in
theory
of where movement cr up
that the qu and as a bl against their
fellow musls
it began most us with a personal
‏trans
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان الذين فرقوا دينهم وكانوا شيعا لست
منهم في شيء
الله
make
opping
that you
have nothing to do with those people
what this mean this means
‏another
isount
that this differing beed
because very quickly
spiral becausean
uses it a tool touse and the seeds of
differing and among the musl
‏our
what is that is supp to us all what are
we all supp to be agreeing upon what
gathers us
what gather us is the rope الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
واعتصموا
بحبل الله جميعا
ولا تفرقوا
[Silence]
الله
سبحانه وتالى
‏fail tourion
and
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
جامع الترمذي
كتاب الله
هو حبل الله الممدود من السماء الى الارض
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
[Silence]
قران سنه
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
unit
‏and
we are
to hold to
not
the book of الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
harانه
وى
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
all
things
great
in the
الله سبحانه وتعالى
لقد انزلنا اليكم كتابا فيه ذكركم
افلا تعقلون
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الذكر هنا بمعنى الفخر
والسؤدد
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم صحيح الامام مسلم ان
الله تعالى يرفع
القران اقواما ويضع به اخرين
الله سبحانه وتعالى
learn
those are guid by not those
gu to
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
قران
all
takes of courage
because
intrusive
it's not just something that a person
can idly
it's not something that a person can
‏a
present
and understand
as intend it will permanently change
that person
because the b of Allah demands change
and action
there no such
‏trر
tr gu
are
time
will have them if it will them will
‏de and
will
think the way a person
what a person eat it changes how a
person dresses how a person behav it
changes the lens through which a
persones himself and others
however when a person
the
‏B
if
away any asect of the will
time
person
because
of mir الله سبحانه وى
‏are
and those away
and ching
away
and last
mention to us the only time
the messenger الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الفرقان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقال الرسول يا ربي ان قومي اتخذوا هذا
القران مهجورا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
‏my
now
timeus
الله سبحانه وى
‏in any
abandonر
com
and for
notand
the qu they embrace many of aspects all
of its aspects
الحافظ ابن القيم شمس الدين رحمه الله
الفوائد
angles that personf
‏in order to
exemption
of this
and to be innocent
of the abandonر
mention that how
spare himself
from abandonر
beingty
‏abandonر
comes in ang
number one abandoning recitation
number abandoning
contemplation
contemplat on thean ofر
‏number
abandon
using the quر as a cure
as a medic for the heart and for the
body
and number
التحكم الى
‏as in our lives
that if a person falls into any of these
one of these five or more
this person is guilty of a portion of
abandonment
in order for us to truly have embraced
the Quran
‏we contemplate meaning when we hear it
when we read it. We must learn what it
means and contemplate it and think to
ourselves.
الله
‏aff
number
seek med and
for our personal is for ourychological
issues for ourysical a we seek
الله سبحانه وتالى
اللهر
and
‏and
even between man and all are
so much soران
وكذلك انزلناه حكما عربي
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وى
‏make us of those
teachings and uphold those teachings we
ask to make us of those are cured anded
byر
and make of those areud andud by
theران اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو
الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك
نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا
قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
او انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك
او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم علمنا منه ما
جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا وعلمنا الحكمه
منه اللهم اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات وترك
المنكرات وحب المساكين وان تغفر لنا
وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت بعبادك
فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين اللهم ربنا
اننا نعوذ بك من الزنا والربا
والغلى والزلازل والمحن والفتن ما ظهر
منها وما بطن
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا
واجعل فارنا على من ظلمنا
وانصرنا على من عادانا اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح
النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم ربنا انصر الاسلام والمسلمين في كل
مكان حيث يضطهدون ويعادون يا رب العالمين
انصرهم على من عاداهم واجعل ثارهم على من
ظلمهم اللهم اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء والنصر
على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استو استووادوا
shoulders
will
based on how
الله
اكبرك
وتبارك اسمك الله ولا الهك اعذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والعصر ان الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
السلام
اشهد
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر استغفر استغفر
আসসালামু আলাইকুম
ইনশল্লাহ
இஷ்ட
இஷ
sch
make
the academy by
‏state liability
for that purpose all you have to do is
participate in the pr state of aona
provides you take the liability and that
to the academy has the forms
available in the back there are there is
information available so you can at
least make sure we start planning for
that last year we collected 128000
and this year
so pleas
and make are parpate
will notad
[Silence]
المؤذن اليوم انا قاعده تدرس
Š